[Music]
might be the first day of september but
it feels more like july or august right
with these scorching temperatures so how
are the kids handling this heat
especially with after school sports
sasha loftis joins us live from valley
high school near eastern and sahara with
the details hi sasha
hi kirsten yes we've been seeing
students playing out here in these
fields all afternoon and hey they are
still going on the tennis courts here
even though it's about eight to 12
degrees hotter than we're used to this
time of year ccsd officials say they're
doing everything they can to keep kids
safe unfortunately many of these sports
like soccer tennis and even football
need to be played outside during the day
so teachers and coaches tell me it's all
about hydration and taking heat breaks
while constantly making sure everyone
feels all right ccsd's athletic director
says it's also important to make sure
kids here at valley are acclimated to
the heat before they even head outside
this is a rare occurrence this is hot
this late in the year this is usually an
early august phenomenon when we do heat
acclimatization for football to get them
acclimated to playing outside but you
can see over here we have soccer teams
playing right now we have the water
truck out there they're ready to go
we're making sure our kids stay hydrated
jackson says they also have trainers on
the sidelines for a lot of these
practices making sure everyone looks
okay and is handling the heat back out
here live you can see a lot of these
water stations all over valley high
school here same way for all practices
whether it be football tennis or soccer
now last year ccst also moved many of
its football games to about six in the
evening so it's a little bit cooler when
those games start and they say they also
rely on parents to of course make sure
kids stay hydrated and acclimated to the
heat before they even step out on the
field reporting live tonight sasha
loftis 8 news now